hello and welcome my name is Jake and
I'm here with John Luke and we're about
to check out a mod for The Witcher 3
that recreates The Witcher 1 prologue
you can download it now on Nexus mods it
is by er XV and yeah once you download
it you just go to you go to new game and
then go to which one pro lock and will
be quiet for this intro and we'll come
back once it's done the northern
kingdoms nurse their wounds for five
years after the great war plague and
famine raged the death toll unknown a
few surviving Elvin and dwarven units
sought refuge amidst forests where they
prepared for a final desperate fight
abominable beasts ruled backwoods
highways and former battlefields alike
in cities and villages folk were left
wondering what had happened to the
witches the Blue Mountains in the north
of Keigwin the year 1275 years after the
great war
[Music]
where am I everything's all right have
no idea where you've been the important
thing is you're alive and among friends
who you look like you just left your
grave
[Music]
I remember nothing
you'll speak soon enough we're nearing
karrimor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Rome Leo get Tris
[Music]
your time nears its end which is enjoy
things while you can
[Music]
wrong you mr. perry i keep repeating
this pirouette always followed by a back
cross perry always barely two days have
passed since they found you mm-hmm I owe
my recovery to you Thank You Tris
remember anything
not much look below I know the moves
through it Barry
cut
I can't explain it but I feel a bond
when we speak I know you were important
Geralt
I need to think time flows slowly at
careworn it worked not bad
take a rest what do you think Gerald is
he ready for the path
[Music]
wait for the rest he's alone
the professor promised 50 Oren's for
every freak we cal he's mine
that's Amir we got company
I'm shutting the gate Geralt grab a
sword off the training forms
okay so yeah that was the intro first
impressions I it's really cool seeing
like all of that recreated in the
individuals of this game yeah especially
cuz care Morin is so similar in this
game to the first that it like it makes
sense it makes a lot of sense right that
was some of the witcher 3 did really
well i thought was when they would bring
you back to older locations they
actually like we created them i think of
the throne room in vizima but a very
brief one where you go to that and three
i went back and looked at it in one it's
like the exact same just like wait you
know high res obviously but yeah like I
think that we just thing is honestly
seeing a traces old voice yeah this is
weird yeah real weird ordinary bandits
would never attack care more on that we
know marigold you could try some of your
famous magic in due time Lambert enough
we need to check the other possible
passages to the upper courtyard
Triss reminds me more in the first one
reminds me more how she is in the books
rather than in which year two and three
because in the books she's much more
serious she's kind of
in the books and she isn't one to and
obviously she kind of changes characters
they're trying to break down the gate
they won't get anywhere without a
battering ram
right now okay so that's definitely an
example of the guy trying like that
asset was not new to three years but
other than that I mean even then like he
obviously put some work into it or they
put some work into it but it's pretty
impressive
yes it's really cool I'm surprised that
another guy coming up here giant bug
which three wasn't used in its place
maybe because it its actions are so
scripted that they it wouldn't it would
look way more likely oh that's pretty
good professor murder-for-hire same with
the the professor it's magic there's a
sorcerer and I forget that guy's name
yeah it looks like they went up in like
straight-up recreated that professor
outfit and stop yeah like what I
remember but obviously higher res
strolling riding my Dania temeria and
Keigwin a real maggot I don't recognize
the sorcerer marigold I'm interested in
whether you can disarm Savola the rest
is witches work I'll try they're coming
the Frightmare is very dangerous but
it's vulnerable to loud noises the bells
in the upper courtyard exactly ESCO
Lambert you'll help me stop the fright
neuron the bandits leo stay behind us
Geralt you open the gate to the upper
courtyard when we're there triskin stop
Zavala and his pet while we prepare to
deal with a professor in the unknown
mage I'll figure something out
let's do this bleed them a bit down here
before withdrawing Geralt follow the
wall and break through to the tower
where there's a passage to the upper
courtyard alone they're just bandits the
one might be infamous you must open the
gate we'll be waiting good luck wolf so
I think bessemer's voice-actors still
the same yeah it sounds really similar
what's the best case that's pretty
impressive
I think as schools is the same as well
not really I that definitely is
different is well other than Tris is
Lambert Lambert yeah he's my friend not
nearly as sassy but yeah that's
impressive because playing Vespa it's
not even into and he's pretty much
barely in one like he's in this intro I
think he maybe pops up again I'm trying
to remember it's been a while since I
played this game he's not really in the
witcher 1 that much it's a pretty big
role in foody so doesn't actually get
back to reaso voice actors impressive
and it looks like this guy's salamander
hood oh yeah Wow today I think this
right here is maybe the reason why I
would want a a Witcher remaster it's not
just the visuals but yeah but you're one
combat is so weird and obtuse it's very
hard to kind of figure out it doesn't
feel great and I think the combat in
Korea is really good I would love to
just like replay the what you want in
this style but other than that I mean I
don't I don't really feel like they need
to necessarily like okay this is this is
all hypothetical obviously it like seems
wrong to read hasn't said if they're
ever gonna remake the witcher 1 but if
they ever did I don't think they
necessarily need to like reimagine it
like they need to make it open world all
the way like The Witcher 1 had like
these fairies like large areas that I
would rather just kind of like oh just
recreate those like on the same scale
but then just pack them in be like way
more detail yeah I that would be awesome
like fix change the combat maybe replace
some voice actors like Tris but for the
most part leave it as is
yeah I agree if the voice acting in
addition to them just also sounding
weird is they're different so the audio
mix since it doesn't sound as
high-quality and I'm not sure if that's
a case of like the post-processing they
did or maybe
got one or didn't so I'm not sure if
that would be able to be like if they
could like just take the old voices and
we do it like at a higher quality or
like yeah okay just straight up I could
rework or all the lines so another thing
to point out is that I have fine hold I
have it I have all of them but I can't
use them because if you remember the
which one you have to get you have to
relearn yeah and I believe in this we do
learn hard and I don't think I can die
oh really
yeah I was worried yesterday slang so on
the menu when you click it says like hey
there's no save states like if you die
like you you get screwed interesting
whether they turn it off just so it
doesn't yeah cuz if this is rip this is
just kind of its own individual thing
oh I love the finishers in this game
yeah yeah man even though like old this
is from Witcher 3 and you go to here and
what your three something about seeing
it right now
like this butcher one style that yes
feels very nostalgic no way through here
follow me dr. Cipolla makes me want to
replay them yeah I've been thinking
about doing like a which are full
Witcher playthrough again like playing
through all three of them and this is
just make you be able to do that more
maybe maybe next year after I've
finished all the stuff I've missed this
year which is a lot I feel like it's
hard for me to justify going back and
replaying
because there's just so much I haven't
played oh that's so cool
I'm kind of on that Hans's Cloney tail
they didn't go like the butcher one long
hair look yeah I don't remember I know
in which you're too you could actually
get get like different haircuts and you
could get the witcher 1 haircut I don't
know if I don't remember if three had
hair higher cuts I don't think it did
but I don't think I actually tried all
the haircuts usually I used the half
shaved for the ponytail with the sides
to Ryan yeah I didn't really mess
honestly I don't really
the funniest one in The Witcher 3 was
like the emo one the emo L yeah yeah it
was like I had it all over them like nah
that's just isn't garel I think that's
why I didn't really mess with over
months like I put it on and I'm like ah
cool but like kind of breaks the
character a little bit for you like a
need to look the way he smells
generally the books yeah I've never
finished the mom but I've read both
anthologies and I think I read like the
flutter Bell yeah the bloody bells kind
of trilogy
it's a miracle you're alive they're
quite good I'm sure watching that you
know but we're supposed to because the
game is based on the buff grasses in the
book bring based in the game it's
actually really good yeah hi I like him
quite a bit
one thing I would love for them to I
think it actually like changes some good
they're fun to read and then play the
game because they actually do kind of
change your perspective yeah you play
these games on their own they're good
fantasy games right and you know great
characters great setting you read the
books and then you play suddenly clearly
are massive chance yeah and even like
one thing I loved about the witches have
ties up a lot of loose ends that were
open from the books right for a guy
don't want to spoil too much but there's
a point where you do something with
yennefer I just can't finish the tree
but you do something with yennefer that
is like almost a direct continuation of
a short story in one of the first books
I think it's the first anthology which
is so yeah I mean it's kind of crazy
like as someone who read the books to
then be like it took them the third game
to finally bring in like yennefer and
ciri who are like major major characters
in the
right like they were really kind of
holding off on them in a way that like
made it feel actually like really like
worthwhile worthwhile right yeah totally
especially Syria because Siri is Siri
becomes the main character in the books
like in the anthologies mainly follow
Carol but the the blood and elves
trilogy actually switches perspectives
and seriously or the main character and
girls just like a major side character
yeah it's it's interesting reading the
books because it's like every third or
fourth chapters Darrell yeah which I
like just cuz it's like you're like
Carol yeah yeah but it's really cool
seeing different perspectives the one
chapters I didn't like in the book Susan
it when it would focus on like one of
the Kings are like someone - yeah this
cuz it was just like all right now we're
seeing a lot of words I don't understand
it really it real politic tea in a way
that I'm just kind of like yeah like a
witch like I like that it's there just
because it's like it adds a lot but it's
like alright this has gone on too long I
want to like go back to Jennifer Geralt
there see really
I know CD Projekt RED is definitely done
with Witcher for now but they've always
said that they've never completely like
quotes that opportunity yeah the the
wordy they always used was was done with
garel which always to me I left is like
oh make a make a cerium I was love a
ciri game you know I just the way series
kind of become some encourage in the
books like I think you absolutely could
make Assyrian and like the way The
Witcher 3 ends once again I won't spoil
anything but it just like if they were
gonna pick up with a character it would
definitely have to be serious yeah
although I can't change write a true but
I'm hassle to her than play it could be
bad you know
you can't do that but yeah no totally
the way they end and the way they end
the game you could absolutely continue
it was Syrian and it would be I think
would be awesome
these stairs lead to the lab follow me
the energy you annexed from the circle
of elements is enough to stop the
witches you trembled yet to complain
Savola would never tell me that the
environments and like this area wasn't
recreated like no so this the the way to
get down here and The Witcher 3 is
blocked by what happens in the which one
one right so this is actually it looks
like it's directly been pulled from The
Witcher 1 just kind of been very
textured a little bit yeah it looks
pretty good from like this cutscene like
you never actually like know who's
around in it oh well you do a little bit
I think but not in a way where it's kind
of hard to tell like this ready but for
the most part like they've done a pretty
good job where I can't
it doesn't feel jarring off yeah the
magic barrier looks solid
we need Tris they're robbing us girl
clear the passage upstairs use a sign a
sign the art I can't do it since I broke
my fingers training along the gauntlet
it means the art at the debris I don't
remember the signs let's go to the
circle of elements a source of the power
you need to try and learn the art
alright that's another thing I've
noticed in the dialogue is a lot of like
that's never being liked I'll teach you
how to do this and I remember in the
actual game like a bunch of like
tutorial menus would pop up yeah
and this is one there gotta just
ignoring that which I honestly I
remember finding that really off-putting
like it's actually really fun watching
the
when I watched when I played it the
first time I felt like I wasn't quite
enjoying the story assess at the
beginning of the prologue because I was
just trying to figure out I see how the
heck you piss of control yeah Lambert
kills the frighteners I'm self and plus
it drops you in like not in the middle
of a story but like a world that's
already been so well established right
and the characters already know about
things going on and you kind of don't
but I think that's why works that Geralt
loses his memory yeah you're figuring
things out as well as Geralt and
something you mentioned yesterday was
like yeah that is kind of trophy but at
the same time it works really well here
especially with what did you more as
thick as the bandits are in the lab
totally something the mage used the
circle of elements to create a magic
barrier a plague you're all children why
didn't you mention the circle Tris child
it didn't seem important if the major
mind with the circle he can create a
stable portal through which he'll travel
to anywhere on the continent taking your
equipment with him alright we made a
mistake but you said the mage was
harmless I said I didn't know him I
think we should protect the lab above
all don't panic marigold which is
secrets yeah that idiot doesn't shut it
off
enough Lambert stop baiting trysts show
us some respect
trace if we go to the lab they'll have
us surrounded
we know tactics maybe we should split up
Gerald's right we need to protect the
lab and kill the frighteners who goes
where only I can break the barrier I've
Besame I'll stay and handle the
Frightmare in Cibola what about you
Geralt
we may both need your help choice right
now what do you think we'll do laughs
okay the lab is important think that's
what I picked in the original in with
Tris so I picked the nila to go home
Tris their skill and Lambert will stay
with me Cibola just cast a spell
something's happening
the ground is shaking feel it they're
breaking through
[Music]
quickly depend the laboratory man it
would also be cool to play this could be
a hard fight gerald witcher's Colin I
have a Witcher game about that endurance
very useful when fighting mages thanks
let's go it have to be a pretty
dramatically different now yeah I would
have to be very good thing about series
you'll go no further white one I'll
summon a powerful demon that will tear
you still be about story play we'll deal
with him and join you at the barrier
under estimating an opponent now the
energy of my people will make me strong
and I hate to work for this guy he's
absorbing in essence like I'm gonna use
you to make me stronger oh no my sore
throat okay the dudes just standing
there we sort of broke yeah what's that
a thing in which or one I'm trying to
remember I don't know I in The Witcher
in The Witcher 3 when I started playing
on PC which was my fourth playthrough I
was like alright I am going to download
a mod where I don't ever have to fix my
darn sword again mostly because of that
little inventory thing on the side it's
like I like that with Bethesda games for
the first time I played through it but
that's the game ok no mods yeah no mods
play it straight like the way was
intended second one oh you're gonna like
cut its head off the second time true ok
no no encumbrance let's just get that
off right away simple is eating dirt
that's what matters
we need to help Tris let's go
yeah the modding and like this is like
one of the more extensive mods I've seen
innovation 3 like they're pretty subtle
like they're mostly just quality-of-life
stuff right yeah compared to 4,000 games
which have a pretty easy to use like
toolset to build mods and implement them
which is kind of a little more closed
closed up so they definitely do exist
but like you said they're the more
quality of life stuff like the moving
come brands remove yeah remove item
weapons great game breaking I turned it
on so like experience doesn't scale so I
get like the same amount of experience
no matter what level I am so I like made
it to the end of the PC version with at
like level 63 which is no I think like
50 which is like pretty crazy cuz metal
finish like at 25 or yeah pretty nice
but like because I want to be able to
play around professor you got those
witches mutagens mm-hmm now that's cool
that's cool
mutations other stuff like my you know
no HUD mods would be cool not quite good
one I mapped turn off HUD to tilde Oh
fill this so I just like tap it turn
everything off then if I get lost that's
cool it actually key bind yeah like I
can't think of another game that lets
you do that oh you know olio very
short-lived in this universe
ah
obviously when I first played the sign
for the books I didn't know but I
imagine people who didn't read the book
we're like Leo's not a character he's
gonna die it's like a view notes that
every buyer game you always start your
money that's gonna die instead Coxon if
they're in the prologue with you
all right PJ is here how did this happen
he attacked the professor I was late
it's not your fault
Geralt we're all to blame Tris barely
made it fighting for us these are bad
times for witches and something tells me
they'll only get worse
is it safe up top relatively some
stragglers up there but we'll deal with
them later you look tired
I'd like you to rest I'll keep watch and
tend to Leo's body music is from the
original to
yeah I I like the music of the original
quite a bit I think music in all the
games I mean three's got some real real
good ones
yeah very ambitious yeah that's a good
way to put it
everything about furry just feels
ambitious yeah
the vinyl is going to be available on
November 24th
once again traces still remaining
that's a relief think we about him there
you go you're watching this holding us
get the insights we need to bid Leo wait
for Tracy you don't have a Twitter to
finish things but first we must make
thank you we'll need to search for
ingredients nothing useful left here I
can do that how do I make the potion
Lambert will give you the formula look
for him by the fireplace he's with our
brave sorceress Lambert he doesn't hate
Tris feels guilty I think the first
thing drizzle here when she wakes is
finally awake marigold
that's Lambert let's get to work later
I'll teach you how to extract
ingredients from monsters I'll be in the
main hall fine
all right yeah so just like spits you
out above that Brian you can't go back
down there I'm kind of surprised that
because there's other underground areas
I can sort of been really hard to do but
like in care more in like secret areas
outside I'm surprised it just didn't
like cut to one of those yeah but I
suppose that works too
Gerald is something wrong no time to
talk I need to make a potion for Tris
you should find a vial of white gull in
the armory on the upper floor grab some
calcium echoing from the evening Hall
look for white stones in one of the
chests if you find any stragglers finish
them
we don't need prisoners the stairs are
through that door I'd go but marigold
lies unconscious by the fire
I'll find a secondary dialogue yeah
[Music]
is that what your sense
[Music]
oh man the sword the broken sword is
buggy fee not much you can do about it I
know hi buddy
yeah you're still cutting them like
butter
easy there we go
all right so I believe I need to give
this stuff to Lambert and then talk to
vesemir and do something for him and I
think we're done
all right he's a whitey and he's in the
floor a little bit
oh is he late he's like what's he
actually thinking and it's upstairs good
you'll need two more things to make the
potion the claw of a mighty beast as I'm
selling Dean resume ax will tell you
where to find them let me teach you the
formula oh no he was just sitting down
yeah you're right oh that was a tough
fight I found a few intruders upstairs
but I understand they won't be a problem
Lambert however let the frightened her
get to him nothing series good you went
after Tris and handle that mage she was
able to salvage some equipment but it
looks like the main devices vanished
our beautiful sorceress was right I know
you did well wolf take this armor and
sword I've been keeping them for now
perfect ours broken
Lambert gave me the formula it's funny
that arm unless you already have white
goes similar to our in one not quite
yeah what next
it's the immune support set what I'm
plus the club monster like the fright
now to skin the creature take a sharp
knife and cut along the torso you'll
find the frighteners carcass in the
upper courtyard once you've extracted
the claw rest by the fire while making
the potion will speak later alright I
let's go at that Frazer cloth
who
like if I recall this is where they're
like teaching you in the game like how
to you know like create potions and
stuff yeah it's been so streamlined in
the witcher 3 though that like it's not
it's not at all the same yeah he's got
yes i have all the ingredients good now
arrest and prepare the potion according
to the formula will speak later
right now we just brew it in the menu
yeah that is a vet is significantly
higher than Witcher 3 our Witcher 1
all right back up the long set of stairs
I remember weird the menus in which are
one two like it's got that like
everything is like an out like a half
circle yeah with like all the nodes and
like weird graphical stuff just like
she's moving like it's looks so weird I
kind of love it but I also kind of don't
yeah I hope this potion helps
Thank You gerald man she recovered fast
was with me he was staring at me saying
things like don't go dying on me miracle
calling me big-headed
I'm so glad to see you what I'm glad
you're feeling better I know we should
set out but I have a feeling we won't be
back perhaps ever would you stay just a
bit longer with me yeah I suppose we
have some time I suppose we have some
time I'm so happy you're back when I saw
you all the feelings I tried to deny
returned stronger than ever
Tris I'm not ready to talk about the
past of course I shouldn't pressure you
I just feel so the powers I'm behaving
like a teenager let's focus on the
present I guess I disappointed you all
forgive me nothing to forgive what I
felt when I learned you were alive hard
to compare to anything oh except maybe
what I feel as I look at you I missed
you so let's see if the best bed and
care morin can hold us oh yeah let's get
that trading card
[Music]
yeah there it is I think that even look
like no not at all it doesn't even look
like we should look like in the original
game and you can see old Geralt model in
the background that's good I think that
might be the edited version too because
in the original bass US release all the
cards were edited to not be new that
might be the end they broke into the lab
killed Leo stole our mutagens and
escaped poor vesemir another prodigy
dead prematurely we delayed the funeral
until you awoke thank you as for the
mutagens their loss could prove
catastrophic let's not lose any more
time unless there's something you'd like
to ask me nope
now we're good you've been waiting we
shouldn't keep vesemir waiting come on
then well I think it's about it for the
demo yeah this is awesome
yeah it does make me want to replay one
two and three again even though I
shouldn't replay three anymore yeah I
wish I kept going I'd like it seriously
it it kind of just like stops the demo
at the end which is yeah definitely and
you can download it right now if you
want if you only do it from PC just go
to Nexus mods I think you need to create
an account in order to download it at
least from Nexus mods less by that I
think this worth it especially if you
never had a chance to play The Witcher 1
this is like a good way to maybe test
the waters yeah and then hey maybe go
pick up the witch's one sure it's on
sale right now yeah Black Friday stuff
you probably cheap yes thank you for
joining us guys checking us out and if
you liked this video make sure to come
back for more they get some GameSpot
see I'll gather what information I can
and find you in vizima Tris don't
Garrett I detest goodbyes I'm liable to
cry and there's nothing more pathetic
than a sorceress and tears don't get
killed Garrett I don't think I could
deal with that again I'll see you soon
[Music]
see uterus
you